Josie you're definitely right and I  would even go further absolutely big  Tech social media is used as a tool not  just for consensus but for manipulation  and there are Bots there's a lot of bots  there's a lot of sock puppet accounts  there's a lot of government officials  the Israeli government even announced  this 15 years ago that they're hiring  individuals to set consensus online to  of course spread the messaging that's  more favorable towards their government  if you think the US government is not  doing this if you think the Chinese  government and the Russian government is  not doing this you're absolutely kidding  yourself and there's a lot of bots it's  estimated according through a lot of  accounting that that you know a lot of  the most popular accounts have the most  amount of bots since Bots following  those accounts like Biden is expected  According to some estimates having at  least 49.3 percent of his entire Twitter  followers to be Bots to be fake